what's up everybody i am back uh do i
look sweaty i probably do because it's
90 [__] degrees in this room and i am
suffering
really did not think i would be able to
get a video out today because honestly
i'm kind of planning on just going
swimming if i can find a place to do it
but uh we're gonna squeeze one out here
and uh today the subject is going to be
about operational transform also just
another quick logistical thing probably
around episode 50 i'm going to stop
posting daily because a
i'm running out of things to literally
talk about and b is that i want to start
putting a little bit more thought into
each video and raise the quality because
i feel like beyond a point you're not
going to get subscribers if you're just
posting these crappy little powerpoints
every day like i've been doing and i
kind of want to put more thought into
the actual interview questions that i'm
going to you know be starting to do soon
so anyways without further ado let's get
into the actual video okay collaborative
text editing what is it well basically
there are a ton of platforms nowadays
such as google drive google calendar vs
code collaborative editing that
basically allow a bunch of different
clients to simultaneously make changes
to one piece of data whether that's a
text document whether it's a calendar
you know an ide for code writing and so
as a result of that you know it's
literally just a recipe for disaster and
conflict in the sense that you know
you're going to have all of these
conflicting rights and you're going to
have to rectify them somehow such that
they actually make sense to every single
user and such that each document
actually converges to a consistent state
but keeping that in mind you know this
is a lot easier said than done and we're
going to see how
you know kind of having to deal with an
array of text or maybe calendar events
or something like that and getting that
to converge is a little bit harder than
your typical crdt problem
okay so here is the big problem which is
that array writes are not actually
commutative so imagine we have two
devices you know they both start out
with poo and now they're going to make a
change locally
and then it's going to get propagated to
the other device so we've got poo first
one is going to insert s at position
zero and the other one is going to
insert p at position three so we've got
spoo on top and poop at the bottom and
now they're going to send their changes
to one another
now we've got spopo and spoop after
basically doing those same insertions as
you can see the documents are not in a
consistent state so how can we actually
get it so that they are because
otherwise this wouldn't make sense to
anyone
well one solution is to use something
called operational transform operational
transform basically accepts the fact
that these devices are going to go ahead
and make their relative changes and then
it's going to consider all of the
changes at one time and use this
transformation function t which you know
i'm going to keep as an abstraction for
now but just know that between
formatting deleting characters all this
stuff it's a very complicated function t
is basically going to take one operation
given all of the operations that have
preceded it and transform it in a manner
such that it makes sense so as you can
see we've got both of these documents
starting out the same way with just b
and c but then once you insert position
a at position zero and d at position two
then the subsequent operations actually
have to be modified a little bit as you
can see now on the left side um
inserting d at position two is actually
going to have to be modified to
inserting d at position 3. and that's
the only way these two can stay
consistent
so like i said it's obviously a
complicated function you can start to
even think about some of the edge cases
that are going to arise but this is
something that actually works and it's
used in something like google docs
however it also has its pitfalls mainly
being that in order for this to work you
have to have an ordering of those
operations for that function t to
actually understand the ordering and
then transform every operation as
necessary so as a result of that what it
means is that every single operation
made to a given document has to either
go through a single leader or some sort
of consensus algorithm in order to get
some sort of replicated um sorted log
and as a result of that that is going to
make things pretty slow so if you have
hundreds maybe even millions of users
trying to make changes to the same exact
place it's going to take a really long
time or it's going to be hard because
the throughput of one single leader node
might not be sufficient there
okay so what is another option well
actually this is kind of newer and it's
more of an up and coming thing but we'll
actually see text editing crdts so if
you recall from my previous video what a
crdt is and if you don't you should
probably go watch that a crdt is
basically some sort of data structure
that each replica can hold locally and
basically every single time there's a
change you can either pass the entire
state of that data structure or you can
just pass that operation that actually
modified it and the entire point is that
you use crdts in order to make sure that
every single replica converges to the
same value of the crdt and so this is
something that could potentially work
really well for text editing however
it's not as easy as something like a
crdt for a set or a counter because
there's a lot of nuance to text editing
in the sense that array operations are
not commutative and kind of the entire
huge thing about crdts that makes them
work so well is that generally they work
with commutative data structures for
example adding elements to a set is
commutative adding increments to a
counter is commutative but it's not so
easy with something like an array so how
can we go ahead and actually make this
work
well this is where we are going to use
the following strategy so basically each
document is going to be
more or less represented as a set of
character and location tuples so if you
look at the diagram here on the right
basically each document is going to
start out the same way we've got b and c
at certain positions and then we've got
this start and end token at you know
position 0 and 1. and we're going to
model every single character in the
document from position zero to one so
now what happens is that when you insert
um a character between two letters
you're going to go ahead and take the
positions of um you know kind of the
neighboring letters of this insertion so
if you're looking at inserting a here
between the start character and b the
reason we're going to get 0.25 is
because we go ahead and
take the halfway point of the start
character in b which is 0.5 over 2.
and then similarly for d if we're
inserting that between c and the end
character we're going to go ahead and do
1.0 plus 0.75 and then divide that by
two and that way when these operations
are actually going ahead and going to be
sent to one another their position
relative to everything else is going to
actually be kept
now if you think about it there are a
ton of intricacies within here that i'm
purposely not going over because
similarly to operational transform there
are tons of edge cases for example you
know what if user a and b put
you know two characters in the same
location
but they were actually just different
characters you know how would we resolve
that conflict the the answer is there
are a variety of different ways of doing
it one of them would be to just kind of
decide an arbitrarily like last
character wins based on some sort of
node order and you know there are
obviously going to be a ton of
intricacies based on things like
formatting um floating point precision
can become an issue if you're dividing
by two too many times you know you're
losing the precision that you need in
huge documents so they're obviously
going to be intricacies here and then
especially they're going to be
intricacies if you know you you write
like 10 characters at once in one
document 10 characters at once in the
other document you need to make sure
that those 10 characters are going to
stay you know right next to one another
and be subsequent as opposed to you know
like interleaving those like the fingers
of my hand going like this what we want
is here you know five characters like
this five characters like this and not
all mixed together so ultimately this is
definitely still an ongoing field of
research but the reason it's so useful
is that it doesn't require a total order
broadcast but instead rather just
something like a causal broadcast in the
event that you know you want to insert a
character and then delete it afterwards
it's important that you know the
document realizes that the character was
actually inserted before it got deleted
and the way you could do something like
this is just by using something like a
lan port timestamp which as we know is
pretty lightweight so being able to use
text editing crt crdts is a lot more
scalable because it doesn't require some
sort of centralized server to have to go
ahead and order all of these rights and
so as a result like i mentioned this is
a really interesting field of research
and it's something that will probably
start coming into play
in subsequent years
okay so overall as we know being able to
deal with marriage conflicts or just
conflicts in general when you have a
bunch of replicas is really difficult
and it's especially difficult when you
have it in a way that commutative
operations are not actually going to
preserve that state right you're going
to not have convergent state if you
don't have a clever solution to this
problem
but that being said
obviously companies have been able to
kind of get these solutions to work like
i mentioned operational transform is
used in google and as a result of that
we can see systems like google docs
which actually work really well at
pretty large scale but even still you
know there's a ton of ongoing research
about this field in things like text
editing crdts and i'm 100 sure that even
though this is a pretty theoretical
field that people have definitely been
asked systems design questions about
this topic before in fact someone even
commented that they've been asked about
operational transform and as a result of
that i think it's pretty important to
cover and it's a super useful topic
okay guys i hope you enjoyed this video
i'm glad to still be getting them out
one at a time and have a great day